this is dr disco
so we have arrived at the first half of
the zygon two-parter the zygon
invasion oh boy
my memory of this two-parter was
that part one had a lot of problems and
part two basically picked up the slack
and fixed most most of them
uh we'll see whether that second part
holds true but uh definitely i was
accurate in that the first part is
actually not great there's a lot of
problems
mostly structural with this the core
concept is sound and
i i was debating whether to talk about
the
um allegory aspect of this in here or in
the next video i'll talk about it here
and if i have any new thoughts about it
i'll i'll do it in the next one as well
but there's solid groundwork there's a
lot of good ideas but there's a lot of
botched execution and some really not
very good moments
in this so this is the one that
basically picks up from the end of the
day of the doctor
and we deal with the outcome of
the ceasefire that was established at
the end of that episode which
that's a good thread to pull on if
you're going to do a follow-up
especially on that story that's a good
one to do because
we were left in a situation where
there's a ton of zygons on earth
what happened to them how did that work
well
we kind of find out a little bit in this
one we don't find out everything we find
out
a bit more in the next episode as well
but that's a solid starting point
and then we have the idea that there are
some uh there's basically a
small rebellion within the zygon
populace so
you have radicalized zygons who are not
okay with the fact
that they have to hide who they are
and they are prepared to go to war
with humans and to try and force other
zygons to join them if they aren't
willing to do so
in order to be able to be seen freely as
themselves even though this is in
violation of the terms of the ceasefire
so you know what let's touch on the
allegorical
element of it it seemed very obvious at
the time and i still believe this that
the intended allegory was
that of radical
islam radical muslim elements you know
that
that whole thing because that would that
would have been more contemporary to the
era
i will say though and i'll probably
drill into this a little bit more next
time
this shows a pretty decent understanding
of radicalization in a way that
spreads out from specifically having to
be
an allegory for muslim extremists in
particular
it has an understanding of
radicalization in terms of
how it works what drives people to do it
how they try and recruit from within
the things they do to [ __ ] the
structure within their populace so that
those who remain will turn to them in
the absence of the leadership that was
there previously
it understands very well a lot of the
elements at play
in an an attempt of a radical minority
to try and radicalize the rest of their
contemporaries and the populace to their
ends
either by declaring them traitors to
their kind or by
getting them on board it it understands
this pretty well and again
even though i i strongly suspect it was
specific to
muslim extremists at the time it
understands it well enough that it
it is broader it can be interpreted and
is actually
can easily be applied to any kind of
extremism
that i could think of just sort of
taking the basics and
and sort of pacing it on various
radicalized groups i'm like no
no this tracks so that's that's really
solid that whole thing
sort of backing up a little bit i like
that uh the first we see if the doctor
is just jamming on the guitar
in the tardis i know some people don't
like the guitar and they don't like the
sunglasses they don't like the hoodie
like i like all of it and what part of
what i like about the
guitar specifically is it's uh it's sort
of a sideways step of something that i
always imagined the doctor doing and
i've talked about this before
which is that i always kind of pictured
the doctor
when he's bored sitting in the tardis
and just
fiddling with the sonic screwdriver and
adding new features to it
new abilities to it uh and
this kind of feeds into that same thing
it's like it's just sitting around got
nothing to do i'll
fiddle with this it's just instead of
fiddling with the screwdriver which is
my head cannon to be fair he's fiddling
around with the guitar so
watch him do that that totally tracks
for me so that
i i do like that and also we get the
first introduction of the idea of dr
disco which
is a little it's a little cringy but
like he
he keeps trying these various things and
he's trying puns and none of it's
working and i kind of like that is
it they're dad jokes the guy
this really is this particular series
kind of
is the midlife crisis of the 12th doctor
and moments like this while i may not
love them in a vacuum i do actually
appreciate them as part of his overall
arc over his three series that he did
so i need to start talking about some of
the stuff that doesn't
work
a lot of it has to do with the specific
execution of some stuff involving the
zygons
first off there's what is admittedly a
nitpick and it's something that could be
leveled against a lot of similar stories
like i could easily level this against
something like stranger things or a
bunch of other stuff but
it still always bothers me when it comes
up this massive
network of underground tunnels that
could not have been entirely
pre-existing
if for no other reason than they had to
make all these modifications to
the elevators in these buildings to be
able to go further down than they're
supposed to
how did they do that and nobody noticed
you know
underground excavation is not exactly a
uh
a silent stealthy operation
so you know secret underground tunnels
when we have no cover story
for when these compositions have been
built and especially with the zygons
like they've got these things all over
london like yeah
no but again admittedly that's a little
bit nitpicky
somewhat more substantive
so the whole standoff in this
town between unit and the zygons
oh my god i hate i hate this scene
so much and i hate the lead-up to it all
of it
so they do account there are lines to
account
for why they are able to take on the
forms of
loved ones of these individual soldiers
there's a line about they can pull the
memories from your mind and appear as
anything
they want they only need to preserve the
body
in order to get more information about
somebody
and really get into their memories and
whatnot and that's a little bit of a
shift
from what we've normally seen from
zygons my first question is wait are you
saying they're psychic
now because you're saying they're
plucking memories out of people's head
fine
whatever but the whole thing starts it
was going to start with a bombing run
of some kind and the person who was
supposed to pull the trigger
doesn't because two zygons appear on the
door that look like
her husband and child now i don't doubt
that the zygons
would use this tactic it makes sense
what makes no sense to me
is she's miles away
how the hell did they know who was at
the controls of that thing
how did they know whose family to appear
as
there is no covering for that it's like
wait
did they did just randomly pick a a unit
member
boy hope it's this one uh where your
family
could have been somebody else at the
controls going that's not my family
boom so there's that and then there's
the actual showdown
with the guy who's heading up he's not
really the head head because the head is
off around the corner and actually in a
way where the geography makes absolutely
no flippin
sense but i i it's that's not even worth
getting into because it's
far from the things biggest problem but
he goes through this whole thing where
he's seeing his mother and there's this
whole back and forth where he's like
asking her questions she doesn't know
the answers to now look
here's what i will grant appearing as
someone's loved one
is a good tactic for delaying a snap
decision if you're going to appear at
someone's level in their
natural instincts of protecting the
people they care about
are going to kick in they are going to
delay they're going to stall
and that gives you an opening so that i
totally buy what i don't buy
is this prolonged conversation you know
you're dealing
with shape shifters and yeah they
this mother gives us a sense of oh they
kidnapped us and took us here
ha again how did they know who was
coming
just think for two flipping seconds
how stupid you think i am and you're
telling me
and here's the other thing if it was
just that one idiot
soldier okay fine
people can be done but he had like a
dozen people behind him
you're telling me not one of these
trained soldiers
specialized unit trained soldiers that
gets established because they can't call
in the normal army
because the entire thing of how the
zygons are integrated
is limited only to unit staff so
these are not normal soldiers these are
unit specific
trained to deal with alien situations
not one out of a dozen or so of them
that are there with guns
thinks no this is a bad idea
and they all go in every
last one of them goes
into this church bull
absolute bull again the core idea of
stalling them by appearing as their
family that's fine but they drag it out
into this prolonged scene and it just
the level at which it works if it to
whatever degree it did work just keeps
dropping steadily the longer the scene
goes on it just
drags forever there's also a bit of
idiocy involved in kate's
subplot because okay a couple of things
here
the first is is it's really badly paced
not in a vacuum not in terms of what she
does in the rate at which she does it
but the points at which that is
sprinkled across
the rest of the episode because she
basically just goes to a town
meets one cop realizes stuff has
happened and then the cop turns out to
be a zygon
that's like half an hour
of real time 45 minutes maybe worth of
stuff
but they keep cutting back to her and
cutting away from the much more
intensive stuff
for her to be bumbling around this town
learning
f all she doesn't learn anything of
significance while she's there
and the points at which we keep cutting
back to her just don't flow worth a
dang and then with the cop like was the
cop always a zygon because if the
couple's always a zygon
why why talk to her at
all why prolong this like there's a
toss-off line with the cop being like oh
i had to be sure you didn't have backup
coming
why why did you have to be sure of that
everybody needs to kill her regardless
even if he thinks backup
backup is coming kill her now and leave
like what
what was the what was the point of going
on for
45 minutes an hour showing her the
evidence of the crimes you've committed
why what are you doing we also get
another really awkward insertion
of the uh the whole hybrid concept
because that gets
brought up as a concept when talking
about osgoode now i will touch on i was
good
i like osgood being back i liked osgoode
as a character i like her use here
and just in case i forget to address it
later
let me be very clear the osgood that
survived
is human like that
she is now i'm not going to do a whole
thing debate
like and some people would be like
where's your evidence well if you want
one piece of evidence next episode her
specs break and since
if she's a zygon her clothes are part of
her body they shouldn't be able to fall
off and be able to break but even
setting that aside
there's a meta reason why she has to be
human because the whole intention of the
balance between the two
ozgoods is that there is one human and
one zygon
and at the end of the next one there's
two oz goods again and we know one of
them
is bonnie so the other one has to be
human
because otherwise that's two zygons
that's not balanced that's not the plan
that's not
the what is supposed to happen and
i yes that's a meta reason and i can't
cite a ton of evidence but like
it's the same reason why
the question of would the flash beat
superman
in a race is stupid to me of course the
flash would win
he has to win he's the fastest thing in
that universe
that's the point of him
so it's not about tracking their powers
he has to win because that's what he
is this osgoode has to be human because
we know the other one later is a zygon
and there has to be a human enzygon for
the balance that's what they
are so if you ever wonder that's your
answer there you go
but it is nice to have her back and i i
like her interactions we get a little
bit more of that in the next one
um trying to think what oh you know what
i did like the twist that clara
was converted at a point that we didn't
see i like that they account for when it
happened
i like i like that they gave her
like this this second you know sort of
second in commanding unit under kate
who is um traveling around with clara
and she would be the obvious one like oh
look
the person at unit who we've never seen
before and is right next to the campaign
is gonna turn out to betray them oh no
it's not because the companions actually
does that oh
okay like that was good and that works
largely because there is the misdirect
of this other woman being right there
and like
well obviously she's a zygoma oh oh
okay nope fair dues so i
that like that was clever and that
worked i
i think that's about all i've got like i
said it's not awful
it's a good core concept and it shows
good understanding of
radicalization and the way that it
happens
but like there's some massive problems
with this and
in some specific scenes that are just
like oh
stop so that's the zygon invasion
let's see if the next one holds up as
well as i remember it
doing uh in the meantime if you wish to
support me and this channel
there is a link to my patreon that keeps
the lights on around here
and in addition to that there's the
usual stuff that also helps me out like
share comment subscribe whatever your
thoughts on this episode or my review
are drop them down in the
comments and let's talk about it and
until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye